KAI HALEY: All right.
Welcome.
Thank you all for joining me.
I'm very excited to be here
today to talk to you guys
about how design sprints
are flexing for success.
I wanted to start by
introducing myself.
I'm Kai Haley.
I'm a user experience
designer and I'm also
a lead of our Sprint
Master Academy at Google.
How many of you are familiar
with design sprints?
Awesome.
How many have you been
in a design sprint?
Fantastic.
That's really exciting.
For those of you who are not
familiar with design sprints,
it's a framework, a
collaboration framework
for answering critical business
questions through design
prototyping and user research.
And the Sprint Master
Academy is a program
we have at Google
for training people
to be sprint masters, to
lead and run design sprints.
So I run the curriculum,
I create the curriculum
with a group of
passionate people,
and I've trained close
to 300 people at Google.
I'm also a Sprint
Master and I run
a lot of sprints
for various teams
at Google, as well as outside
with our partners and startups
and even some nonprofits.
So I'm really excited
and passionate
about this methodology and happy
to share it with you today.
I wanted to start
with a personal story.
When I joined Google
five years ago,
my design and product
development cycle
looked a little bit like this.
Product manager would come to
me with a request or an idea
wanting me to make some mocks.
And I would ask them
a lot of questions
and try to figure out
what they wanted to do,
spend some time making the
mocks, maybe a week or two,
send it back to them.
Invariably there would
have been miscommunications
and we would need to make
another round of edits
or changes.
We would work on that,
and if I was really lucky,
we'd be good enough to send
it off to the development team
to be built.
Usually the engineer
would have a lot of ideas
and a perspective as well,
and ask a lot of questions,
and sometimes even
send it back and say,
there's no way we're
going to build this.
Come on, guys.
So this might take four weeks,
it might take five weeks,
and never at any
point in this process
did we take it to
our users and say,
do you guys even want this?
Is this going to
meet your needs?
Is it going to solve
some of your pain points?
So you can see how
inefficient this process is.
It's not a great way
of collaborating,
and frustrating for
everybody involved.
I was lucky enough to
participate in the first sprint
week at Google.
The Ads and Commerce
team brought together
people from different
product areas
to spend a week focused
on innovating new ideas.
And this was really
inspiring and exciting to me.
I was so enthralled
with this process
that I volunteered to
become a sprint master
right at that moment
and started running
design sprints with my team,
with other teams at Google.
And it really changed my
life and changed the way
that I work.
So it's really amazing.
And what it does is bring
product managers, UX designers,
researchers, developers all
into the conversation together.
These perspectives are all
being added to the strategy
conversation at the beginning,
and this really increases
collaboration and improves
actually executable ideas,
because everyone's able to
put their input in together.
So it's really a
cross-functional process.
So today I want
to share with you
how you can use sprints in your
product development lifecycle
from idea all the way
to launch and beyond.
I'm going to talk a little
bit at a high level about what
design sprints are and then
share three examples of how
teams are using sprints
to create success
for their products.
So what is a designs sprint?
It sounds like a lot of you
are pretty familiar with this,
so I'll try to go
through this quickly.
As I mentioned before,
it's a framework
for answering a critical
business question.
Maybe you want to know how
to increase your customer
acquisition.
Maybe you want to improve
specific small flow
of your product, like improve
your onboarding experience.
Maybe you want to create a new
product and brand new vision.
Sprints can be
used for any stage.
They can be used at the
beginning, the middle,
and as you evolve over time.
Really, it's a
shortcut to learning.
Rather than going through
this process where
you start with an
idea, you spend
a lot of time building it
and getting it exactly right
and then launching
it out into the world
and learning at that point, we
shortcut that and get straight
to the learning.
And sprints allow us to do this.
So where does this come from?
It was created at Google by
a couple of different people,
Jake Knapp, Nadya
Direkova, and some others,
and it's evolved over time
among different groups.
But really it's a set of methods
that we've polled and selected
from the greatest hits of
business strategy, design
thinking, user research,
and even some psychology.
And we've ordered them in a
specific way, tested that order
to get it just
right so that we are
using the most effective methods
in the most effective way.
And we've put them
into this framework
to support divergent
and convergent thinking.
So you'll see
throughout this process
ways in which we diverge
and then converge again.
And we've tested this
for different goals
and different
deliverables over time.
But the thing that really
makes it different,
and the thing that I have
found so valuable-- because I
did a lot of design thinking
prior to discovering sprints--
is that we set a clear goal
and a clear deliverable
at the beginning.
We time box it.
We don't spend a lot of time,
maybe at most five days.
And it's very user-centered.
We put the user at the
center of that process,
so we know that we're
building the right thing
for the right people,
and we do this very fast.
So the first phase,
understand, is
where the team gets together
and creates shared knowledge
and a shared brain.
You map out the problem space.
And we do this by
inviting knowledge experts
to give lightning talks.
These are 10-minute,
really quick talks
on different aspects
of the problem space.
So you might bring
in a business person
to talk about the
business opportunity.
You might look at
a competitor audit
of what the space looks like.
You might look at the
technological opportunity
or constraints.
You'll do an existing
audit, talk to users,
these sort of things.
The sprint master will
capture all of this content
that you're creating on
whiteboards and on the walls
as you're creating the sprint.
So this is like the
visual brain that you're
using and pulling from
as you generate ideas
throughout the process.
And we have some
different methods
for capturing these ideas.
One of them is called
the How Might We.
And this is a technique for
transforming pain points
into opportunities.
We listen to our
users, and you might
hear them say
something like, oh, I
can't remember my passwords.
I have a really hard time.
I go to this website,
I go to that app,
and I just can't keep
track of them all.
The how might me
that you would write
from that is, how might we help
making password entry easier?
And so we're looking
for things that are not
too broad and not too narrow.
But this is a way to capture
these opportunities as you're
listening to your
lightning talks
or listening to your
user interviews.
We share these so
each team member,
each sprinter gets to
share out the opportunities
that they've captured.
And then we categorize them.
We affinity map them.
And this helps us
to provide structure
to how we look at
the problem space,
and then allows us
to prioritize, what
are the opportunities
that we should really
focus on to have the
most impact for our user?
And where are we going to
start sketching our ideas?
We also have a
user journey method
that allows us to really get
into the mindset of our user.
We look at their experience
from the first to all the way
through to the end,
experiencing with our product.
And this allows us to
surface pain points, which
is where we're pulling
those opportunities from.
What does the experience
look like today?
Where are the challenges
and the problems
that our users are having?
How can we improve
that and create really
a better user journey for them?
The understand phase
usually concludes
with a team conversation
about what success looks like.
What should the success
of this product be,
and how do we
drive towards that?
So we're all on the same page
working towards the same goal.
Then we move into
the sketch phase,
which is where-- this is
the diverging phase where
we're going to generate
a broad range of ideas.
And we might start
off by looking
at a comparable problem.
Often good ideas
are not new ideas.
They're just borrowed
from other spaces.
So we might go and pull
in some examples of things
to inspire us.
We might do a
note-taking exercise
where we collect our
thoughts, and this
is to prepare us for our
really, really fast sketching
that we do called crazy eights.
We give people eight minutes
to sketch eight ideas.
And what this does
is help people
get beyond their first idea.
You really want to get to
a broad range of ideas,
and often you kind of get
stuck on that first one.
That time boxing motivates
people to come up
with a lot of ideas, and this is
really the individual ideation
portion of the sprint and
where the meat of the creation
happens.
We close out the sketching
phase by narrowing down
to a very well-articulated
solution sketch
that each person will create.
And this is an
opportunity for people
to sketch out what
they think is the best
solution to this problem.
And then they take this
into the design phase,
where the team
decides, as a group,
what it is that they want to
build for their prototype.
What do they need to
take to their users
in order to get the learnings
that we're trying to get here?
And we use a number of
different methods for deciding.
We have a dot voting method,
where we give people three dots
and we say, pick
the thing that you
think we should really build
that's going to have the most
impact for our users.
Sometimes we'll do
a heat map voting
where we let people vote
on specific features,
and this lets you
pull and choose
from the variety of ideas
that have been created.
You don't have to just
commit to one idea.
And if you find you're getting
a lot of groupthink or people
are all sort of following
one or two people,
we have a note and
vote method that's
sort of like a secret voting,
which lets people express
their opinion and their
idea more authentically
so we don't have as much
of this group think.
At the end of this
phase, the team
has come to a
conclusion about what it
is that they want to prototype.
And moving into the
prototype phase,
they start off by
creating a storyboard.
And the storyboard
is where you map out
exactly what you want to
build in your prototype.
And this is done
as a group effort.
The important thing to
remember with prototyping
is, we're not building a
fully functioning prototype.
We're just creating a
real enough experience
to take it to our users to
get the feedback that we want.
So it's like a facade of
the idea that you have.
So if you're
creating an app, you
might just do a
set of static mocks
that you can click through.
Or if you're creating a
space or an experience,
you'd want to try to
prototype that actual space
and give people a
feeling for what it is.
You need to create the most
useful and real experience
so that you can
get your learnings.
And the important
thing here is we also
do this really, really fast.
We generally don't spend more
than a day on a prototype.
So it's amazing what you
can accomplish in a day.
And sometimes we'll even do
it in two or three hours.
And then we move into
the validate stage,
and this is the
really exciting moment
at the end of the
sprint when you
get to take your
ideas to your users
and get that feedback
and that learning.
And we encourage
everybody in the sprint
to be there to get to
hear from their users
and see what their
experience is.
This is also a time when we
might bring in a stakeholder
to get a stakeholder review.
If you haven't had your
CEO in this context
of the whole sprint,
this is a great time
to get feedback and
validation from them.
And then you can also do a
technical feasibility review
if you need special
engineering input to make sure
that what you designed
you can actually build.
This is a really
good time to do that.
And this is the
end of the sprint.
And at this point, you've
got some really good ideas
on how to move forward.
And you may end up deciding
to run another sprint,
but at this point, you've
got some learnings.
You know what it is
that you want to build,
and you can take the next step.
Space is really
important for sprints.
Conference rooms are not
great for creativity.
So we have a couple different
types of spaces at Google.
This is our garage, which
is a maker space where
we run a lot of our sprints.
And it's a really
fantastic place to work.
Gets people out of their chairs,
standing, working together,
writing on whiteboards,
and not just sitting
at desks falling asleep.
So many of you, maybe, have
heard of the Google Ventures
Sprint book that's out there.
They have a five-day model.
And if you're a startup and
this is your only product
that you're working on,
spending five days on it
makes a ton of sense
and is a great use
of your time to save yourself
weeks and weeks of development
time.
At Google we have
product teams that
are working on many
different products,
so it can be hard to
get everybody together
for five days.
So sometimes we'll adjust
the schedule a little bit
to accommodate the
needs of our team.
We'll do some advance
work, some planning.
We'll pull those
lightning talks in.
We'll pull in all the research.
And we'll adjust and
compress the amount of time
we spend on our methods to
meet the needs of the team.
And sometimes we
might even go down
to two days or even one day.
There are some one-day
examples that I'm
going to share with you today.
And in here, the
important thing is
that we are getting validation.
We may just not be getting
it within that one day.
We'll do it later, or
we'll look at other ways
to get that user validation.
But the user validation is
really, really important.
And the way we're
able to do this
is because we have
our sprint masters.
And as I mentioned before,
we have at least 300 now.
And they're all trained
in these methods,
and they know how to work
with the product teams.
They help them define their
goals and their deliverables
and then adjust the
schedule and the agenda
to be realistic to reach
those goals and deliverables.
So every sprint
has a sprint master
who is the facilitator
who works with the team
to make this happen.
And also depending on where you
are in your product life cycle,
you might be at the
beginning, where
you're doing a
project initiation
and you might need more time.
Or you might have
a new forming team,
so you might also have
collaboration needs.
If you've been working
together for a long time,
you might have different
needs for what methods
you want to utilize.
So the first example I want
to share with you today
is for a team that used sprints
at every stage in their product
life cycle, from
project initiation
all the way to launch.
And this is a product
called Google Home Services
which recently launched.
It connects consumers to
qualified local service
providers.
So if you need a dishwasher
repairman to come to your house
and fix your dishwasher,
Google Home Services
can help connect you to
somebody appropriate and nearby
in an easy way.
This idea came out of
the 2014 Sprint Week,
where we brought together
150 people for a week working
on 23 different
product ideas ranging
from moonshots and brand new
products to evolving existing
products.
And the team was
focused on creating
a vision for the full
product experience.
And they really wanted to take
this to stakeholders for buy-in
to get project kickoff.
So they needed a vision deck
as their deliverables and high
fidelity mocks of the key
moments that articulated
that full narrative.
They were looking at what the
experience was like today,
what it should be in a year,
two years out, and even four
years out.
So they were really looking
at ideal experience over time.
They started by understanding
the problem space,
doing lightning talks, inviting
some experts to come and talk
to them about what the
experience was like now, what
the competitive space was
like, what the business
opportunity was
like, thinking about
technological requirements.
We generated how might we's
and prioritized and categorized
them.
They sketched ideas for what
the different states would
be in those key moments and what
the overall experience should
look like.
And they took these early
stage sketches to their users
to get early validation.
Because it was a
brand new idea, they
wanted to be sure they
were on the right track.
Before they even started making
their full-fledged mocks.
They said, does
this fit your needs?
Is this going to
fit into your flow
of trying to find a plumber?
And then they responded
to that feedback,
started working on their
mocks and their prototypes,
and looking at how can
we help them diagnose
the problem-- this was
a big pain point that
came out-- and ended
up with a vision deck
that they took back
to their stakeholders.
And this project was approved.
The vision deck did its job.
Everyone said, wow, this
is a really great concept.
We absolutely need
to invest in this.
The schedule for
this sprint, so you
can take a look at how
this framework has flexed
a little bit, was three days.
And they spent the first day
understanding and sketching.
Early validation on day two.
More sketching, and then
deciding and prototyping
on the last day.
After this they
ran another sprint
to look at the
experience from searching
for a provider to booking
a provider, so just
a small slice of the
product experience.
They really wanted to diverge
and get a broad range of ideas,
and they wanted to make
sure they were considering
all the different aspects of
this particular set of flows.
And they wanted very
low-fidelity deliverables
for this, user flows
and sketch mocks.
So they identified what were
the steps, what was the piece
that they wanted to solve for.
They reviewed existing
research that they'd
done before, a lot of
reminding themselves of,
these were the pain
points and the things
that we heard, reviewing
competitor experiences, what
was good about that, what
was not so good about that.
They generated how might
we's and prioritized those.
Where should we focus for this?
What are the best ideas
that we have here?
Sketches.
And then sketches were really
where they ended the sprint.
And the UX team took
this back to their desks
and started actually
building mocks from this.
So this was kind of a
little turbo boost, more
of a brainstorming workshop.
The schedule for
this was a one-day
because they were looking
for pretty low fidelity.
They spent the first portion
of the day understanding,
and then sketching
and prototyping
in the second half of the day.
The third sprint
that they ran was
to design the end-to-end
assistive experience,
so helping people to
diagnose their problem,
helping them to connect
with a good provider,
and for both sets of audiences,
consumers and providers.
So they had two users.
And they wanted a
high-level user journey map
that would let them create
a prioritized project plan,
figuring out what exactly do
we have to build for launch,
and what can we save for later?
They all got together, reviewed
their use cases, thought
about the goals for the sprint,
what do we need to cover here?
They spent time
thinking about what
are the needs for
each user, generating
how might we's for the
providers versus the consumers.
They even did some
more user interviews
because they wanted to
fill in the gaps on things
that they had missed before.
And then they created end-to-end
user-- very, very detailed user
journeys.
And they identified specific
steps in the process,
and this helped
them to prioritize.
Well, maybe we
don't have to worry
so much about the grow
at the end or the promote
at the beginning.
To get to launch, we need
to focus on this here
in the middle.
And that was something that
the team really needed in order
to move forward.
So they did this in
a day and a half.
They spent half of the first day
understanding and figuring out
what they wanted to create,
sketching, deciding,
and then prototyping
and validating
with the rest of
the team afterwards
and creating that project map.
The launch product is
on the search page.
You can go search for
a plumber near you now,
and you'll get an assistive
UI that will take you
into an immersive experience
that will help you
find a plumber for your needs.
And then you can also
do this on desktop.
And it really helps
people to connect
with multiple providers.
And that was one
of the pain points
that came out of all
of their interviews,
was managing all of
these different plumbers
is actually really
difficult. So they
solved for some of those key
problems with this product.
And they utilized these
sprints at the beginning
for the kickoff, in the
middle as a turbo boost,
and then towards the end
to prioritize what they
needed to build for launch.
And the outcomes were,
as I mentioned before,
generating approval to
initiate the project, really
creating a shared
vision for the team
to help them know
what they were working
towards over the long term,
giving a little turbo boost
in the middle to their
design, and then innovating
ideas towards the end for the
full end-to-end experience.
The second example I
want to share with you
is for a team that used a sprint
to actually start a completely
brand new business.
It was a Project Kickoff.
And the business is
called HarvestPort.
It is a marketplace for
sharing agricultural assets
like vegetable bins and farming
equipment and stuff like that,
allowing people to monetize
when they're not using it
in the offseason.
And they wanted to define
that product offering
for the new asset
sharing marketplace
and create a shared
vision for the team.
So they had an idea, but they
really wanted to figure out,
what is this idea and what
does this space look like?
They wanted user flows
and high fidelity mocks
that they could then take
and build from later.
So they were looking for
a mid-level of fidelity.
We all came together and
invited lightning talk speakers,
experts from the
agricultural industry,
to come talk to us about what
the business opportunity really
was, what the
existing systems were,
what the competitive
space looked like.
And one of the really fantastic
things about this brand
is that we actually had
farmers-- there are two of them
in this picture here-- with
us for the entire sprint,
creating how might we's
and sketching with us.
And this gave us this
constant validation
as we were working together.
We also interviewed some
potential customers.
So we did the user
interviews as well
to get a sense of, what was
the environment that they
were working in?
What are their Wi-Fi
connections like?
What are their
technological capabilities?
And this really helped
us to understand
the broad base of users.
We generated how might we's and
prioritized those, and created
user flows looking at, what is
the experience for the lender?
What is the experience
for the borrower?
Sketched ideas for what the
UI would look like for this
and shared out those sketches.
And then as the team decided,
what do we actually really want
to make mocks of for this team?
What is our prototype
going to be?
So we voted and decided
as a team on that,
and then had UXers
working really, really
fast to create these mocks to
show what the experience might
look like.
And I think our prototyping for
this was like two hours, maybe
an hour and a half.
And so we created mocks
that show how might you
represent your assets, how are
you going to search for them
and suggest pricing
or post them?
These sort of things.
And you can see the
fidelity is pretty good.
The team was launched
recently, in the last couple
months, so a year from project
initiation to marketplace
launch.
And if you have any vegetable
bins that you want to monetize,
you can sign up here now and
offer them to the community.
Their structure was--
this was a one-day,
so we accomplished
a lot in one day.
And one of the reasons
we were able to do this
is that we actually had
our users in the sprint
with us, so we were validating
through the whole process.
And it was really,
really fantastic.
This sprint was the kickoff,
but they took this with them
as they formed their team
and started the company
and started utilizing this
process over and over again
until they got to launch.
So they definitely embraced it.
And the CEO was so
excited by this process.
He was really impressed with
how it could be spontaneous yet
really structured and focused
and keep us on strategic course
the whole time while still
allowing for that creativity.
So the outcomes were, we
created a shared vision
for the product, really
galvanized the team
and brought them together,
and formed the company.
Also secured their
largest investor
and key advisory board, which
is a pretty unusual thing
to come out of a sprint.
The last example I want
to share with you today
is focused on UX and
engineering collaboration.
This is a team at Google
called Firebase Analytics.
Some of you guys might
be familiar with it.
And the UX designer
and the developer
were feeling a
little bit like this.
They felt like they weren't
communicating that well.
They didn't really understand
each other's roles and the work
that they were doing, and
they felt like they weren't
collaborating that effectively.
The UX designer said, why
don't we run a sprint?
I think this would be a really
great opportunity for us
to improve our collaboration.
And the engineer looked
at the framework and said,
well, that sounds
cool, but can we
really focused on collaboration
rather than user validation,
and pull the methods that
emphasize collaboration.
So their goal was to explore
and build new interactions
and experiences
for their product,
but to do it together,
so with engineers
as opposed to the designers
off creating ideas
and then throwing
it over the fence.
And their deliverables
were a set of features,
prototypes, and a
game plan for how
they were going to work
together moving forward.
They decided to give
their sprint its own name.
They called it a blitz.
And because it was wintertime
and their team nickname
was Snowman, they
called it a blitzard.
And they wrapped up the
sprint by going to DQ
and getting a special
blizzard made for them.
They really wanted to
create a safe sandbox
where they could brainstorm
together effectively.
So they all got together and
created shared knowledge,
had lightning talks, brought in
information about their users,
really took a look at what
were the pain points of them,
what problems were they having.
And they did this
sketching and prototyping,
sketching and prototyping
sort of structure,
sharing back with each other
after they started creating
ideas throughout the process.
So a much more cyclical cycle.
Cyclical cycle.
Their schedule looked like this,
where they spent the first day
on a small portion
of understand,
and then sketching and
prototyping and sharing back,
and sketching and prototyping.
And they found this to be a
really, really effective method
for them.
They have started
using this repeatedly
throughout their cycle.
So they did one in the fall.
They had another
one a month ago,
and they found that
they pull it in whenever
they need some focused
time to really inject speed
into their process.
And the UX designer
and developer
feel a little bit
more like this now.
They have a better understanding
of each other's working
methodology, their roles.
And when the developer
is coding and he's
coming across UI challenges
that haven't been resolved,
he'll now walk over to
the UX designer's desk
and say, hey, let's solve
this together instead
of sort of working in silos.
So it's been really fantastic
for their collaboration
and for their innovation.
So the outcomes are a
deeper understanding
of each other's work.
The designers become a lot
less precious about design,
not fixating too much on
getting it exactly right,
but trying to get through
an iteration process faster.
And it's changed the way
they think about prototyping.
They said prior to this
process, they kind of
thought about prototyping
as a throwaway activity.
You're building something,
but you're not actually
going to use that in
your live product.
And so they're trying to shorten
that gap between prototyping
and building.
And this allowed them to
decrease the time from idea
to mock to prototype,
and to increase
the number of executable
ideas, because they're really
focused in on, is this viable?
Is this a good idea?
And created a strong sense
of ownership with the team.
Everyone really
had an investment
in the ideas that were created.
So you can see how
we're shortcutting
getting from idea to learn fast,
and doing this over and over
and over again
throughout our process
to really get to an
effective innovation method.
And we don't approach sprints
in a cookie cutter way.
No two sprints are the same no
two sprinting team is the same.
Every product has
different needs.
And it's a flexible
framework that we use.
Based on the goals and the
deliverables of the team,
we can adjust in order
to meet those goals.
So it's a really,
really fantastic method.
And if you're going to start
thinking about running sprints
with your teams, it's
important to understand
what they're good for.
They're really great
for user validation,
really fantastic for
speed and collaboration.
So thinking about how
you want to structure
your sprint for those needs.
And hopefully I've given
you some inspiration
to try this with your teams.
Some of you may have read the
book that Google Ventures wrote
called "Sprint."
It's a really fantastic read.
I encourage you to get it.
We also have a playbook
on developer relations.
And design.google.com has
a lot of great content
that we'll be updating there
for sprints in the future.
So stay in touch with us there.
And I think we have time
for Q&A. So questions.
Yes.
Should we use the--
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
if you guys could
go to the microphone in the
center of the room for Q&A,
that'd be great.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for
the wonderful speech.
I have a question that trying
approach the design sprint
into our current company.
And in order to
make that happen,
I think one of
challenges is that really
make the decision makers
onboard about the design sprint.
For example, the decision maker
may involve a CEO or as COO
or a CPO who potentially
they didn't see directly
value before this design
sprint actually went out.
And also I think another
challenge for my company
is we have very
tight release cycles,
and also our company's very
data-driven, so in that sense
that everything
should be communicated
in a way that have a direct
impact in certain KPIs.
So I think I talked to
several designer in this room,
so it looks like this is
a really common issues
among a lot of tech companies.
Just wondering how do you
guys solve this problem.
How do you align everyone
into this design sprint
in the very beginning, make sure
they are willing to be involved
and participate.
The [? delegated ?]
to the outcomes
they may achieve by the end.
KAI HALEY: Thank you.
That was a very long question.
I think what you're asking is,
how do we get everybody there,
and how do we justify
them dedicating the time?
Is that correct?
Because we actually
do, at Google,
have metrics showing that
this has increased innovation.
It's increased the
number of ideas.
It's decreased
the amount of time
we spend going round
and round in cycles.
And it's decreased
the amount of time
we spend building things
that users don't want.
So in terms of
being data-driven,
we have data to show
that, which helps.
And we've been
testing and utilizing
this methodology for the
last two and 1/2 years.
And so we've seen a lot
of fantastic results.
Being able to tell
people that this
is what it will accomplished
for you helps to get them there.
We can't always get stakeholders
into the sprint itself.
But we involve them
in the beginning,
at the understand
phase, and then we
have a check-in at the end.
So they don't have to dedicate
three days or four days or five
days.
We just make sure that they're
there for the initiation
and that they've signed off on
the goals and the deliverables.
And so we'll have some planning
meetings at the beginning
to get buy-in from everybody.
This is what we want to
dedicate our time towards,
and this is the outcome
that it's going to be.
And everyone agrees
to that beforehand.
And that helps people to
actually come to the sprint,
because they know this is
what we're going to create.
And we actually
really do need this.
So that's the way
that we approach it.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So you mentioned the
design sprint book.
And I was just wondering how
related to the design sprint
book that came out last
year from O'Reilly,
if they were similar or related,
this is the same process?
KAI HALEY: You know,
I just got that book.
So I can't really speak to
the origin of that book.
Most of this is in there.
So I'm under the impression that
they pulled it from some teams
here.
But as I said, it's
a very big company
and there are many different
teams utilizing design sprints.
So I can't comment on
the value of it as a book
because I haven't
actually read it.
But my understanding
is it has a lot
of the same information in it.
AUDIENCE: Actually I
have another question.
And you mentioned you brought
in users to actually validate
during the sprint.
I think that's awesome, and
I was wondering how you time
boxed that for the sprint,
because I would imagine
you have to limit the things
that you can learn and limit
the things that you
put them through,
or put the users through.
KAI HALEY: It
depends on the user
and the capability of the user.
So I think it's a
really good question.
With the farmers
and business owners,
they were capable of
participating and contributing
through the whole thing,
particularly because this
was a marketplace,
so everyone is
sort of a free agent
in that marketplace.
But for example, the YouTube
team will bring in kids
and do co-creation
exercises with them.
And they can't, obviously,
participate in the whole thing.
So I think you have to customize
it to accommodate what kind
of user you have.
And so traditional
user interviews
are the way that you do
that, or site observations
where you go and watch
them in their environment.
But if they're capable of
generating ideas with you
and sketching, then it's really
valuable to have them there.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thank you.
KAI HALEY: Yeah.
Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
for that presentation.
I'm interested in
the [INAUDIBLE]
My question is, do you change
[INAUDIBLE] of each step
while doing the design sprint?
So I think that
sometimes understanding
may take longer time.
So that do you have any
tips to arrange [INAUDIBLE]?
KAI HALEY: Well, it
really depends on what
your goals and deliverable are.
And sometimes you'll spend a
lot more time understanding
if your goal is very
broad and if you
need to spend that
time sort of narrowing
in on what's going to be
the target that you're
going to focus on.
So sometimes you might
take a whole day,
you know, an entire
day for understand.
And sometimes we might
just take an hour.
If you have a really good
understanding of the problem
space and you're just bringing
and surfacing the content,
and you're not spending
a lot of time discussing.
But in terms of tips
for figuring that out,
you have to get a read on
the challenge and the team.
And sometimes people want to
have a lot of conversation.
And that will lead to a
longer understand phase.
So I've certainly
been in situations
where the team needed to have
the conversation because one
person had one
perspective, another person
had another perspective.
And in that understand
phase, you're
sharing those
perspectives and coming
to a common understanding,
and then making a decision,
is the product going to be
this or is it going to be that?
So sometimes that can
take a while, it's true.
But the thing with the
sprint is, you actually
have a timer up here, and it's
like, you've got 10 minutes
to come to a conclusion.
And you'd be surprised
at what people will
do when that timer goes off.
They're like, OK, we'll do it.
Yeah.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: When I've participated
in sprints in the past,
and the ones you
mentioned today,
it's been mostly around
launching new features,
new products.
I'm curious, from
your experience,
if you've seen this work
well with other things,
say, design-driven initiatives,
if you're dealing with,
say, a lot of product
or design debt
that's like cross-platform
inconsistencies, product
hierarchy, is this mechanism
effective for helping
solve those challenges as well?
And a lot of those may
not involve users as much.
It should always involve users.
But it's a little bit different,
I would say, kind of process.
KAI HALEY: Yeah.
Your users may be more
complex at that point
because you've got
multiple people who
are engaging with something.
It is effective for that.
It can be more complex.
And you have to think about
using your time efficiently
and trying to organize the
problem a little bit more.
And I've only done a couple
that are more larger processes
or cross-platform.
And what I often do
is I'll divide it.
So I won't try to tackle
everything in one sprint.
I'll say, let's
look at this piece,
and then you solve that and
then take it to the next one.
So if you can-- even like
that user journey map,
or you can sort of divide
it up into sections.
And then each section will
maybe inform the next one.
But oftentimes you can't bite
off everything all at once.
But I certainly
encourage you to try it
with something like that,
because it's a really great
collaboration method.
And the other thing
I encourage people
is to try other methods, too.
I mean, we've selected
30 from over 300
out there in the world.
But the framework
is flexible and you
can pull in other methods as
needed based on your needs.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Can you go into a
little more detail
around what the sprint mater's
role is during the sprint,
and also, who can play that?
Is it anyone?
KAI HALEY: Yeah.
It's really great
to have somebody
who's good at
facilitation, who is
able to read the room well
and get a sense of how people
are feeling and how they're
responding to each other.
So we often have UX
people because it's
a very user-centered process.
But really lots
of different roles
can take on the role of
facilitator, provided
that you enjoy that kind of
work where you're oftentimes
corralling people and asking
people to make decisions.
And so you have to be
comfortable with sort
of holding to your
rules and saying,
OK, well, this is
the time frame,
and we gotta keep moving.
So people who are more
used to being taskmasters
sometimes are helpful,
but that can do it gently,
because-- I mean, I always
start a sprint and say,
I'm going to move you along.
I'm going to cut you off.
It's a sprint.
We're going to move fast.
So people who are good at that.
And the important thing is being
able to pivot at any moment
during the sprint, because
you're learning new things
throughout the whole process.
And at any point in time you
might just adjust everything.
And so you'll change
your schedule,
and you may end up
changing your deliverables.
So you have to be flexible
and able to think on your feet
really well and have a
good sense of product
problem solving,
like really helping
the group problem solve.
AUDIENCE: So that
person isn't sketching,
isn't doing the process.
They're the kind of bystander
that moves it along.
KAI HALEY: They are
the facilitator.
And sometimes they might
interject some ideas.
And I've certainly run sprints
for my team and my product
area, and I'm a designer
so I'm invested in it.
It's a little bit harder,
because you really
want to sketch and
generate ideas,
but you're exhausted from
getting everybody excited
and keeping everybody
focused and engaged
and talking them
through every exercise.
So generally we
recommend that people
don't try to be a sprinter
and a sprint master.
We say you'll be much more
effective if you focus
on just being a sprint
master, and look
at the process as opposed to
the content of the sprint.
AUDIENCE: So I have a
question around when
you go into a sprint, it could
be that you're spending a day
or two working
together, collaborating,
and you have to kind of
block out your schedule.
And how do you cancel
out all the other noise
that's coming in from other
projects and other PMs?
And how can you just
focus on one thing
and not worry about the
million other things
that you have to do?
KAI HALEY: It's
really challenging.
It's very challenging for teams.
Sometimes we'll go offsite.
So we'll take the whole
team to another location,
and then people can't duck out
for meetings and take calls.
And you change
their environment,
and then everyone can focus.
So that's one thing you can do.
We set the ground rules for
the sprint at the beginning.
We say, we're asking you to
be here for this time period.
If you need to jump out
for one call, that's fine.
But if you're in
a sprint, you're
in a sprint from the
beginning to the end,
because it's very disruptive
to jump in and out.
And you're really creating
this collaborative space
and this team.
So when people
leave, it disrupts
that team building
that's happening
and the effectiveness
of working together.
So it's a challenge, though.
At Google it's become a culture.
So every team here is sprinting.
And so people are more used,
to seeing the auto response,
I'm in a sprint for three days.
Sorry I'll get back to
you at the end of the day.
So there's a little bit
more of that expectation.
And I think as you're
able to make that culture
shift within a company,
that will help some, to say,
OK, this is actually something
that we're all doing.
And so we'll respect
about space and that time.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
KAI HALEY: Absolutely.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I guess this works
perfectly, because I
was going to ask you about
the timeline that you set up.
Have you found that
it's better to do it
in a block of a day as
opposed to two hours one day,
three hours a day?
KAI HALEY: Absolutely.
Well, the framework and the
process, like I was saying,
the methods are ordered
to build into each other.
So as you create this
shared knowledge,
as you create all
these opportunities,
it starts to generate
ideas in your head.
And then if you
jump into sketching,
you've got those
ideas and it's really
this-- you have this
brainstorm and creative moment.
If you wait another week,
all of that is gone.
So the stages build
into each other,
and so that's the other reason
why we do it all in a row.
And we give people breaks,
and sometimes we do 10 to 5
instead of 9 to 5 and try
not to wear people out.
But I always encourage
people to do it in succession
and not break up and kill
that creative moment,
because this is really about
innovation and ideation.
And we're setting it up so
that you are in the best place
to generate the best ideas.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
KAI HALEY: Absolutely.
Last one.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
As a non-Googler, are
there any opportunities
for any sort of formal
training or workshops,
or something more low level
than-- this is a really
high-level presentation.
I would love to be
able to exercise
trying to be this sprint
master and to get feedback.
And again, not being
a Google employee,
do you know of
anything like that?
Is there any
opportunities there?
KAI HALEY: Well,
you can buy the book
and go try and run
one with your team.
And I think you've
read it already.
That's what Jake recommends.
Get together with some
people and just try it out.
The best way to
learn is by doing.
There are some
meetups I've seen out
there of people who are getting
together and talking about it.
Maybe approach a nonprofit.
I want to run a sprint for you.
A lot of nonprofits are
looking for UX support
and it would probably be really
excited at the opportunity
to try out the process.
Things like that, volunteering
your skills for somebody
if your particular team is
not ready to take it on.
But the more experience
you can get the better.
Absolutely And I wish we had an
external Sprint Master Academy
that I could invite you guys all
to come to, but at the moment
we don't.
AUDIENCE: That's great.
Thank you.
KAI HALEY: Yeah, absolutely.
All right.
I think we're done.
Thank you guys.
[APPLAUSE]